[Music]
welcome to the Samuel Leeds podcast on
this week's episode we're going to be
talking about property developments and
how you can make six figures as a
property developer discussing the ups
and downs the highs and lows and showing
some of mine and my business partners
personal failures so our listeners are
ridiculously blessed and fortunate have
you on the channel dude you are the most
expert property developer person that
comes on the channel but you're the
hardest person to get you like to forget
that a lot hardest person to get a hold
of friggin successful killing you I've
only ever had you on the channel once
before doesn't know this is Ben Machado
you guys I only married a manatee a
closer to man yeah yes I'm joined forces
the property business is taken to new
high is been an amazing journey so far
I mean wedding we're set for even high
Heights well we went I went from having
a you know like a very residential
portfolio yeah but I know I had the
castle and stuff like that but that was
the absolute golden gem that was the bad
boy favors like you know you know you're
a partying there's all these little kids
and this is not one overgrown big kid
that was the castle in my property well
I'm still nurturing the big cat the big
bad boy yeah obviously bought land built
houses yeah we've got so many millions
and millions of pounds in the pipeline
of deals so now it's been awesome have
you found like the last six months it's
been incredible it's obviously a lot
different to what I was doing in the
sense that I'm out and about literally
all the time looking at land looking at
new opportunities analyzing stuff
running Dede knowing that we are betting
on ourselves to make it happen now
instead of you working hard to try make
someone else rich you're now working on
backing yourself for it yeah for sure
you know pay yourself a six-figure
salary yeah awesome
I don't I don't pay myself a ridiculous
hour I think I think my salary is humble
you know but it's not about the money
it's about the enjoy it's not about the
journey for sure
you know it's never gonna no matter
which road you take in life you just
have to grind and get it yeah we'll see
actually look out for that one because
we're doing an update but what you'll
see from there you'll be slightly
standing behind right just right
directly behind you see baby you are we
make it happen person you're the
director of the property company fine
you find the deals you cost manage the
deal 16 years in construction 16 years
in the industry which is also and we've
had so many deals recently that have
been almost after you actually give you
something have to give me the gun
Sammy always is to bring the small deals
that we used to go I don't want to look
at that but actually recently you've
been passing along some really good
deals
no thanks a trouble yeah actually yeah
this there's a couple I won't going to
see misdeeds about them but probably
maybe for the next with the next show
yeah next episode we might we might
discuss a bit you know what's funny
though with the type of deals that we're
doing together yes now like my small
deals if I'm step outside a house a
residential house no one can know where
that house is because every house kind
of looks similar so if I'm at Sunderland
stood out sign us a mid terraced house
with a white door no one knows the house
where is when the deals that we're doing
and it's tough like an ex bowling club
and it's just so obvious if we film it
the people will know it yeah and then
what happens just people come in try to
operate it twice I don't wait to be
there
I don't know if you've said this before
but we had the first one was we see a
piece of land in the middle of nowhere
and they recognized it so you post a
picture and someone comforted I know
where that is they recognized the grass
I love the second I thought I was filled
and I just took a selfie Norman oh and
then people are and they described that
is at this location the Planning
Commission and I'm like oh my goodness
at the time the second time were in in
East Midlands yeah why the site well
with a famous investor yes and someone
walked about 200 meters and we're
thinking hard
let's try walk away but we couldn't cuz
it was now awkward and first thing came
across and they gave you a handshake and
yeah it's nice you and they didn't
recognize the famous invest it was like
what yeah he was more famous than I am
yeah I didn't let him live that down
either and that's the last time I've
taken anybody call him right now this is
your life this is your life right now
I'm going to answer this how do I answer
yes yes yes what's up down in Andrews
I'm well I'm just we've been we're just
filming a live podcast yeah man you're
on the podcast right now it's going
really well I'm excited to be doing some
more deals with you over the coming
weeks and months so awesome well I'll
get Ben to give you a call back when
we're done
see you later bye this is awesome when
you've got business partners who
actually phone as well people recognize
deals we do have to keep it low-key
that's why you hide away from YouTube
but I think to meet you a lot of our
personal branding recently you have been
talking there's been what about when you
are I mean you did a video and you're
like this is my youtube channel is what
you're going to turn you there I went on
it's coming is coming at this one will
be the second video on it yes so it's
gonna be awesome
yes obviously it's Matt Lee's related
yes big deal right now you know what
Matt Leeds so Matt Leeds doctor at UK
yeah spell em AC l WDS
that's that's your surname am I so known
boom although if it was my checking
younger leads it might be a little bit
hard to remember it's be a lot of copy
and pasting I had to learn to spell
match a keen young I remember Satyam
McDonald's yeah with a little napkin
just practicing how to spell my Chuck in
younger and you've reading it right down
to the pad tiles well impressed I met
you mention it you said it straight away
McCrea and it means what cut horn
cutting horns cutting horns good deal ok
so we've got a lot of business partners
and here's a really interesting as well
I was stopping my own growth because I
was thinking I only want to invest my
own money yes I don't want to be over
leveraged but then I'm thinking I'm
teaching people how to invest other
people's money that's how I got started
but now I've got too lazy gregor don't
kick my ass I've told the story a
million times what Grand Coteau said to
me talking over the hill mm-hmm he's in
better shape than me at the time maybe
now I'm catching him up he's made he's
more more rich than I am he's telling me
I'm over the hill I'm 28 he's in his 60s
and so I said what I wanted to do
differently he said you need to start
joint venturing you need to collaborate
in business you to collaborate in
property you need to open the doors more
yes you need to stop being so
small-minded and invested in yourself
you need to sell some of your smaller
houses you need to refine that some of
your bigger houses so I've sold houses
managed to know you know how does I've
sold over how many moments so many this
one I have sold seven houses this markys
seven houses and the thing is it's not
that I'm saying I'm selling off my
properties yeah I'm selling them to put
them into bigger deals bring the money
in come on
Mackie's bring it over cash flow wise
yeah I'm good you know I we can't lie
it's not all been rainbows
no it's not and that's what I would say
about the journey you know it you have
to roll with the punches the thing is
we've had the thing is I have sold some
houses refinancing stuff for that but
then obviously ghetto with that money
we'll put it into this project this
project the other project yeah we commit
to the projects but then unfortunately
property is not a liquid business it's
not it's time it does takes
so I have some things fall through and
some and some and some lending take
forever and stuff like that
which they're made us stretched so I
think that how do you stop as a
developer or is it as a property
businessman doing big deals yeah how do
you how do you stop this whole yeah how
do you get so assess things for
everything that we're doing now so
upside from the usual dee dee when we'll
talk about the great yarmouth in them in
in a few moments but I suppose it's
basically cash flowing so as part of the
dee dee one of the key things that I
like to do which is foolproof in us I
suppose as Mac leads is we'll get our
appraisal would do as much TV as we can
on it but we'll send it out to finance
ears and see what's your appetite to
lend us this if we got it and if you
know in advance before we buy something
that yeah there's a 90% chance or 100
percent chance we can get the funding
for it yeah it's obviously alleviates
that pressure and that risk because as
you know the way we structure our deals
we include our what costs for managing
it and so that means that our salaries
are covered in our overhead costs for
our offices our staff etc so that's all
covered in there and each month when
work is done when we send when we get
the contractors valuations or whatever
we send a bill including our costs yeah
to the financier to say we've incurred X
mana costs including our time and
efforts this month and the sandwich is
and can you please pay us so we are
covered at every single point of the
process yeah and then we still enjoy the
big pie who writes it and yes the
profits yet and you have to have a lot
of profit in these deals yeah there's so
many people bringing me deals I'm doing
this I'm gonna make you know I'm gonna
make 10% on the deal and it's like you
know what I just leave you enough
cushion man yeah like the castle we had
a lot of cushion and that's why when
things have gone a little bit not wrong
but when we found the pressures on you
it doesn't matter too much because we've
got 73 push it we've got a seven-figure
profit yeah in it so it's kind of all
good but you need that cushion
that cushion that cushion and I think as
well for me like my business if I if I
had the most conservative frugal month
ever yeah well I didn't I didn't buy any
properties I didn't bring any events
just paying for my staff and my
mortgages and stuff like that it's over
quarter of a million pounds a month
so I've got a quarter of a million
pounds a month in overheads that has to
be paid for like that's big it's big
that's big quarter of a million every
month so it's kind of like when I
started I'm ever getting my first like
rent to rent deer but probably saying
I'm not oh my gosh if the tenants move
out I've got to find 200 pounds yeah now
it's like I got a fine cause I may be a
gap what are you gonna do you know which
is which is I mean do you think that you
need a good a bit of an appetite for
risk or do you think you can do it so
that it is completely safe nothing's
ever completely safe that's for sure
it's suppose I said it's more how you
manage the risk in your coping mechanism
within you always going to have the risk
and some people there their risk
tolerance is higher than others yeah and
I guess that's what sets people apart in
terms of success as well yeah so it's
been able to take the risk and also know
how to manage the risk but the thing is
that was robbed with the risk is I was
doing the most safe investments every
year ago like for instance let
money-lending yes I would lend someone
money they pay me seventeen percent
return guaranteed I'd have a charge on
the property so if they didn't pay me
I'd take the property yes they'd also be
a guarantor as well personally I know
they've got other properties so it's
like that's not really risky I mean you
can say anything's got risk but you
could have money in the bank and the
bank it can do so
things can happen there could be a pie
and we could all die you can get hit by
a bus tomorrow you could get robbed but
you could so sometimes people Trombley
tell us I've so much then interest the
banks they put it in Bitcoin you have a
big conquer crash it's there's always
always something always gonna be real so
I guess the key is to bring to make it
as risk-free as possible
yeah but usually the higher reward the
higher the risk yeah exactly and so long
as you've got the backstops to manage
the risk
remaining the residual risk you find so
for example on our property deals what
we do is we have we rely on consultants
professional indemnity insurance and
also we also get project insurance as
well yeah and it obviously the leap they
all cover certain amounts of risk but
each time we we pay someone to take on a
bit of risk yeah fair enough
eats into our profit but we stay sane as
sane as we possibly can the thing that
we see a lot is developers start a new
project and can't finish it and then you
can often get a really good deal 100%
but I've been in the situation where
I've always been that do you know what I
I don't think this developer who hasn't
had a tough project no key thing that we
know is but you might not know Melissa's
kids but you end up giving away stupid
deals to do this with the castle well I
know what the castle I'm bridging and
the bridging fell yeah and then I had to
raise personal money gave away very good
returns yeah it's virtually paying back
now then the bridging came in and it's
like when you get stuck what about that
guy that we spoke to just give the very
general chance
bobby's land got planning permission for
111 houses did four run out of money
yeah and then tip to us do you want it
do you want the rest yeah we're looking
into that right now
right but when people get stuck you can
often help them definitely get out and
and I've been on the receiving end of
that and you and it's so funny because
you're like thank you so much you're so
grateful but you're actually kind of
gonna exploit this cachinga chinking to
call people up and upset alized enjoys
the development sometimes yeah what I
think more than anything now is cash
flow management no one's coming and
we're getting an F dad I find our
finance director at the moment we've got
full-time accountant we've got a full
force on finance manager we've got a
little finance team and there's like
real forward them full time but now
we're looking to get a finance director
just to take away the pressure of cuz
I've done stuff though I've taken
bridging finance out and expensive
I know it's common I'm gonna make a load
of money toes okay but then I've got
money sad
in properties where I could refinance
and get three and pay 3% but I've got
time but if I'd have planned it better
you could have yeah preparation a game
and said yeah I know you live when you
learn don't you and the key thing is
learning the lesson not focusing too
much on the ass-kicking I suppose and
you've done that yeah and you're doing
that but luckily because I've got you
know quite wealthy yep and I've got
money
I'm alright but I feel like if I had
done this game ten years ago I could
have gone back heroes yeah philia
definitely because if you can't get the
money oh I'm moving being stressed out
about being able to buy my grandmother
back grand from my grandma bought a
house nineteen house and I'm ten or have
I have to fire the heirs on everything
how am I gonna get the 15 grand
but then actually the the property went
up in value I was all good and and and
she ended up wanting to extend it anyway
but but now it's like if you said you
need fifteen grand like you know that
would be all right no it's like that is
like oh you need to get a million next
month
you rang you a brand new food sounds
saying that they're doing this industry
yeah there are improvident this talked
about it on YouTube non ironically we
were talking about that just before the
show started when you're inside CEO
coffee saying there's there's not a lot
of people who talk about the things the
mourn that they go through the bad
lessons and the great lessons yeah which
is a shame because I feel the more and
more people shared like this the better
and better people would be at developing
and sharing the contents and and in
focus well I got to the point where I
could literally just retire forever you
know yes forever and passive income
never have to push it on the property
side
relax I can have a bit of a training
business because I enjoy speaking you
get so bored because I know you so well
[Laughter]
over the hill so now I can how can I
take my property business not just
ticking over to but to a whole new level
and I'm pushing myself I'm stretching
and and I we're putting we've been
putting the last six months of course
pounds every business yes and I've said
to you now I want it even I want to even
start using other people's money more so
and I mean we've working on that yeah
well made some great conversations and
and well doing he's doing deals with
people obviously just received a phone
call just there yeah shout out to Darren
he's an awesome guy he's an awesome guy
and he's and that's the thing it I think
we've said this rough from the beginning
whilst we want to work with absolutely
everybody I know we can't but we have to
work with people we can actually work
with I'm sure that's one of those guys
downs done the crash course Terrence on
the academy Darren I think down I only
did the Academy just to get our
attention which is cool but I thought
people do this the same as um Kevin
Kevin Stuart plays for Hall he joined
the Academy but I think part of the
reason did that was just to kind of get
my attention here because if someone
rings me up or something I want a chat
Simon can we talk Samuel come with me
it's like no I mean dude I got like I
get a hundred messages like that a day
but okay he's join the Academy mmm he's
a pro football player yeah
any messages made I'm not cool I jump on
I'll jump on a call with it great guy
and the next thing we spent a day with
him it is and he's don't mention he sent
me a deal we we were about to do a joint
venture with him
I caught me where that one was now but
anyway we spent the day with him and
then he messaged me and he said actually
Samuel there's a guy who are net from my
youtube channel one of my YouTube guys
yeah we did a video together and he said
he's got a deal and I'm interested in
doing the deal with him instead of you
yeah
now from my perspective genuinely bottom
of my heart I don't care if he doesn't
deal with me if you just do with someone
else yeah I just want the deed to
succeed and and and and I spoke to him I
looked over the deal with someone else
and he said I'll only do it you know if
you kind of check it over and town he's
good
I spent I must have spent you did as
well yeah we did yeah we do above did
spent hours over it yeah and said to him
it's great go ahead definitely and and
and that's awesome and then you've in
this industry you want to go far you've
just got to be us all we're about
helping people adding value creating
good karma you know you never know who's
gonna
next deal nah so it's always about
trying to keep their relationship going
everybody wins there's enough slices of
pie there is to go around so there is
being greedy but people are greedy that
they are some very greedy people and
I've worked for some very greedy
investors yeah developers in the past
and they're the ones that their projects
always go wrong do that yeah because the
thing is some business people where we
do business we want everything to be
win-win not just win win win win win win
we round a table we want to pay orders
to win everybody we want the JV partners
we want the buyers at the end the
sources everybody has to get and we
believe that with the right deals
everyone can win but some people though
they don't want that they want they want
lose win they want to find the builders
as little as possible they want to get
the greediest percentages with the joint
venture partners they want to get you
know do the littlest work so that the
property looks okay but then you sell it
and then the buyer ends up for dead yeah
yeah Mac leads we're not about that no
tell me about tell me about your visions
for this year
my visions for this year so we are
working obviously with you join major
partners yeah well looking to scale that
yeah and working with even more
investors and create our own pool of
cash and can readily invest in great
deals that we've already got for
guaranteed return for hands-off
investment anybody willing to invest
would you have a cut-off point though
because we can't take like contra quit
here and there yes so basically if
someone's got say 100 grand I was
actually working on 250 grand to fifth
deck yeah so they've got okay so they've
got 100 200 listen and they want to have
a chat and they could do stuff what
they're gone they go on that leader
website Mike Lee's website drop us in
drop us a no but they have to be I mean
we can't talk about publicly on YouTube
we can't talk about you know these are
the kind of returns and this is the kind
of deal it's against FCA regulations we
just can't do that so basically if
there's a qualified investor by call it
I think the definition of a qualified
investor going to the FCA is a thing you
need 100 grand that's why I said 100
grand you think but if you're qualified
investor and you want to do
you want to go you want to go for some
big girls you're up having a
conversation hundred percent having a
conversation yeah seeing if we can do
some business together that's awesome I
said on my youtube video if you move
back
I said 2028 I just want to do two deals
but personally I don't like to be big
deals yes I want to make a million quid
on each time each deal on a couple mil
and I'm happy rather than doing 15 10 20
deals or whatever yeah
but then actually the profits being less
but at the moment at this right we've
kind of like got a couple of deals
already in the bag yes but uh yeah Sian
I'm inside 100% excited hundred percent
excited but yeah just do I know we
mentioned we're gonna chat about the
great yarmouth deal yes because that was
the deal that actually fell through
because we're not talking about rent
events and lease options and HMOs and
all this stuff small deals yeah I'm like
guys this is easy if you do it right
applause but develop mine I don't want
to tell people anyone because you know
what when you're talking put in six
figures into deals and stuff honestly
you don't know what you're doing you can
lose it you definitely can you
definitely and you can lose it the first
deal can be a last deal yeah if you get
to the end of it because I'm trying to
create people on the planet I'm trying
to create more people that are
financially free I'm trying to create
people who success stories the last
thing I want is people commenting on my
youtube saying Samuel I did a deal lost
everything now I hate property aren't I
hate you too like I just want people to
succeed so my advice would be if you're
doing a big deal make sure you are the
joint venture with someone that's got
experience like us for instance who's
got experience will potentially will
joint venture or if you're not going to
JV you didn't on your own start with a
small deal then work your way up because
you're always gonna mount mistakes in
your first deal 100% but yeah talk to me
about great yarmouth deal yes a great
yarmouth one of your students came to us
with that deal yeah exactly Kate he came
to you came to us with a deal and I
actually had a chat with him and a DfE
the first time I had ever been deal fine
that's a day actually signed up for the
Academy
he's doing quite well you want to get in
with us you've got to come to the
trainer come to training so it's not
working as the network starts at the
crash pad yeah so we've actually
developed a good relationship with him
but anyway down into the deal it was for
seven properties in Great Yarmouth a
part of the world I had never been in a
never thought I'd ever go
but the deal looked good on paper so I
went out and had a look at it Chris no
this is a rally okay yeah working on
something with Chris as well
yeah cool yeah this is Riley Riley to
water and he lives in in Norwich area
yeah and anyway it's got planning
already which is great particular box
dearest
so why away what is o7 apartment 707
houses three bit houses and a nice
little secluded plot off the main road
look great on paper the fact the numbers
I suppose which we interested in the GTV
was of a 1.4 gdv meaning right yeah
that's it Kosovo and value and the cost
to build it all was just under minute
quitted nine hundred and fifty grand so
you so you're buying a piece of land
yeah how much 280 so you bought it I was
a negotiated price as well okay so you
barn the line for 288 yeah you didn't
spend in a million that was included in
the cost okay so you're spending like
720 grams yeah so all in there's a
million and then the gdv grouse develop
a value is 1.4 one more for ya so you've
made hundred grand 400 grand yet
planning permission permission already
it was gonna be a relatively quick build
figures purchase price development cost
and value that's nice but but so problem
if the list of the DD I'll go through a
couple of things that made a note just
to keep me on topic you know what this
is so for as long as that thing is if
you didn't if you weren't a conservative
investor if we weren't conservative yeah
we didn't do what I do diligence
hardcore cuz we are quite conservative
although I'm although we're young and
I'm very loud actually we're very I'm
one of the most negative people property
right I'm like what's the gvv you know a
noble I have you got a Rick's value let
me like I'm really conservative you're
even more conservative
so before balance that well so before we
bought the land we did our due diligence
and not only that but also the due
diligence that we did a lot of people
have to pay for survey stuff but because
we've got good relationships we can kind
of lean into yeah what did we find we
get a good we get a good find the SI
checked out which is I investigation the
land was looking all right environmental
survey was looking all right but when a
flood risk assessment which is well I'll
just focus on rather than go through the
full list of DD items so the flood risk
assessment is basically if you're
building in an area that's near a river
of which this one is it can be within a
flood a flood zone it is a problem but
it sometimes it's not so much of a
problem bless you
sometimes it's not so much of a problem
but in this particular case it was
because it's a flood zone three area and
I was looking to potentially look past
that if the person who then is gonna buy
it can get insurance on it easily
yeah because then obviously we would
then build we don't want to hold on to
any of this stock we want to sell it all
quickly yeah it is the key because we
would always want to get our cash back
out if it was to rent as in to keep and
rent potentially had to push maybe but
because of the fact that it was actually
in a flood flood risk and he wasn't
classified as an actual risk of
something actually happening we decided
to pass on it which is even if we
capture images ourselves I mean there
could be a flood but really the risk is
probably not letting a flood from our
point of view it's actually our eggs-it
strategy to sell it it's gonna become
really tough because no one's gonna want
to buy it that's it because they're
gonna it's gonna come up on a red flag
when they bought the solicitor's can
flag it up yeah then they're gonna get
their insurance quotes gonna be sky-high
and we did all that DT we rang the
insurance guys to ask them how
technically no would you insure this and
we had two or three insurance in yeah we
could but x y&z reasons and those bits
of concern were like actually know what
man is just being greedy let's just
stuff there is something that you have
to check every time you're buying a
piece like me every time I but that's
one of the first things they check flood
flood flood risks what it was previously
used for yeah
and what's it mirror as well and and how
do you how do you check how do you check
that how do you check if there's so
there's the Environment Agency yeah so
I've got some good contacts and there's
a online software that you can easily
Google and just Google may flood risk
check flood risk check there's this
software that you can pay for sometimes
you get like free trials like 14 days
for usually just picking up a phone pick
up a phone
yes BT so on that alone with that
because whether some other issues as
well but that alone would that be enough
for you to pull out no so that was one
that was probably 75% I was like that
was like serious I know as well that
there was some issues with us not being
able to get in contact with the maybe
yeah so there was this right Nexus site
there's a massive derelict warehouse
yeah and because the the plan that got
planning site layout that got plenty the
houses were quite the foundations of the
houses were right up against the
foundations of this building we didn't
know who the building owner was we
couldn't get in touch with them we can
find out any information about them they
weren't on the registry it was quite
difficult to define so we thought in the
time that we have to move its gonna take
too much too much time and hassle and we
don't want to have to buy something and
then get held to ransom oh yeah that was
only thing there was a potential run
some strip yeah there was so the
restaurants the ransom strip yeah so
yeah that's a nasty thing so off the
main road we're in a nice location
because we were like behind all that
house the greenery the standing they
looked amazing driving up to it but
along the side road I guess off the main
road there's some houses there that are
owned and that's their main access and
the agent who was trying to sell it to
us said oh no no no it's part of the
title deeds of the of the houses and
stuff
I know a Land Registry obviously quick
check who owns what and it wasn't a
hundred percent clear and then after
some more phone calls we found out yeah
we owned it but because these are these
other houses have been accessing it for
so long we started thinking what trouble
could we get into if we wanted to say to
them listen you're gonna have piling
piling rigs coming across all this
construction
plant coming down this road non-stop all
day every day yes and get permission to
amicably build it may may have had to
pay some compensation to them and who
knows what their comes and also who
knows legally if they've been using that
as there's like squatters right yes
if someone's lived in a house so I don't
know what the I can't remember off the
top of it but yeah but it's just a risk
that they could say look man this is
this is our only eyes you've been using
this for years therefore if you want to
if you want to use it and you want to
control these stuff though you have to
pay us and then they could chart that
could quote whatever they want it's just
a potential it's just it's just an
annoying problem when they're obviously
so many more sites in the country to be
yeah it's me found so this activity page
but you know what though a lot of people
especially on their first deal they see
a few problems and entrepreneurs
generally optimists yes I am a
natural-born optimist and you think I'll
be okay and you really want the deal to
happen I live a flood risk but I'll be
fine yeah but you can't no basically
like no that's not it may not find
something the numbers do due diligence
and make sure that there's UD whistles
the heck out much as you can as much as
you can yeah yeah
so we unfortunately we had to pull out
but I spoken sooner I spoke to him today
I said listen don't you know don't
really start because this was gonna be
his first or a deal with Commission said
find another one you know and private
through and he was quite happy that we
actually took our time to look at it as
well which was great yeah and I said
listen anybody who's on Samos Academy
you've got a you know decent that's an
opportunity that you think this might be
good yeah feel free to share it but
again on the Mac Leeds website which is
a Mac lead you can yes if people have
got deals yep did they want and it's got
to be there's got to be good profit if
they're big development deals and I'm
talking maybe a minimum 100 grand profit
in the deal many month minimum then send
it to us we'll have a lock
yeah and then you some quick comment if
you if you're an Academy member of
course they're more look at it properly
but you know if you're not and it's
there you can send it if it's really
juice if we don't respond to means we're
not interested respond but we've only
got there's only so many somebody said
we've got it
money if you've got money and you want
to put into deals get in touch we can
have a chat and we are open to
collaborations 100% and if you just want
hands off listen I've got money in the
bank it's just sat there doing nothing
and you want to invest yeah speak to us
I mean does people ask for training on
development it's something that we might
do down the line yeah at some point but
but the best way to learn is to do best
lately so probably I would just do it
with us yeah do it with us but we have
so many interest in deals and you've got
to walk away everything has taught me
better about you I know you've seen and
I've seen it egos room people do parties
man yeah he goes you don't want any egos
in development so a lot of people think
they're very qualified to be developers
but sometimes it's not necessarily that
they qualified it's just that they've
got a big ego their dad did it behind
did it or ever and they've got
purse-string yes
and they've got contacts etc but equals
can get in the way yeah it really can
get in the way
another option you guys getting the
white web bar there's a project going on
and the developer is so bothered about
seeing the project finish because of
their own ego they won't walk away from
it that's the other side of the coin
definitely yeah
formidable feelings right you feel if
you feel like but actually win the
sometimes winners quit man yeah so you
have to know when you just have to win
and if you if you can walk away today
and just make nothing that's fine but
but if you continued with it you might
make hundred grand but you might lose a
million walk away walk away best case
worst case likely case hundred percent
the worst case is gonna bankrupt you
walk why don't get caught up in the
feelings not only a project yeah it's
only a project caught up in the feelings
whereby they don't like you just got
it's gotta be about the money man that's
the reason why the business what about
where dude at the moment we're going to
details all that yeah but where there's
a couple of people involved and there
I wanted to be like this and this would
be ideal and I wanted to be a since like
honest just do what makes his money
makes money I guess I guess the
exception to that what about like with
the castle for instance yeah we're quite
sentimental about the castle hmm
we love it and although we are going to
make good money on the castle and you've
even even even come on on that you're
managing it so you're not even gonna get
a slice of profit which is gonna be sick
but but the thing is that's not just
about the money for us is it the castle
no the castle is a baby man it's but how
where's the conduit that sounds like a
contradiction now because I know what
about the money but then I will say this
the thing is you have to think about the
long-term game so if this emotion is
definitely tied to it but there's such a
much bigger game too in the sense that
if we get that completed or when we get
that completed rather how many councils
yeah we'll be like oh you guys did that
restoration yeah because at the moment
that is the most notable great - listed
restoration project up and down the
country yeah and heritage England are
all over that they're watching us like
with with Hawkeye is you know they've
every time they come on they've got such
great things is saying they're really
looking forward to seeing it done so
once you get that done just think of how
many more recommendations like are
you've got that building up in Scotland
or down in Bristol where it's gonna be I
know a developer who did a great job in
roofs for now have a chat with them to
see how can do Jeremy he said opens up
also is oels up a lot on the financial
point of view and because of the history
and I mean the Free French soldiers have
literally flown down through France to
take me out for dinner in Mayfair London
amazing that they want to come down to
the castle upon completion and celebrate
all I think that the value I mean when I
bought the castle it made the newspapers
when I started the works
it made the newspapers upon completion I
just think the value of that given the
history and them and the majestic
something you value I know we very
valued at six million yeah yeah but I
think that six million
everyone I'm really happy with six
million but I think that it will be a
lot more than that
[Music]
see the value
hard to say down the line yeah I think
down the line it'll be great yes oh yeah
of course yeah I mean it's got that the
building is got its own Wikipedia page I
don't know many buildings that have
their own Wikipedia page so there is
something about that building that's
very special and it does have a place in
my heart and I genuinely care about the
history having met the Free French
soldiers and and studying the history
I mean I'm not a historian but just it
is just amazing and there's people that
want to get in on the deal that want to
come in and joint venture with with me
on the deal to finish it and they want
to do it not for the money but because
they genuinely want a part of the
satisfaction of restoring it I go say
there's some things you can't put money
on yeah you know that's that has to be
considered the value as well yeah
something just can't put the money on
advice to someone wanting to get into
development advice don't aim to know
absolutely everything about the process
know enough to know who to ask for
information and also know enough to be
able to go into a JV with your eyes
opened and don't just JV with the wrong
person that's the other thing yeah
sharks in industry you get kicked in the
face way to Sunday or not even sharks
but sometimes just massive optimists
yeah and and that and I hate to say this
because it's an industry that I've been
in for the last 16 years
but sometimes showing your Diels the
wrong person especially when you get in
it getting into it people take your
deals man yeah they take them and they
they whisper little birdies whisper
everywhere before you know your deals
gone yeah that's building it's it's
unfortunate
I've never feared that I've always just
spoken freely about my deals I'm never
fairly but it has happened
a lot it does and I get why you say
about a lot man keep it under strap in
your pocket a little bit and and if
you're starting out you know get your
NDA disclosure agreements and to be fair
I say that with anybody who approaches
me with a deal who I know stops or
starting out and once we have a look I'm
like ever you got an NDA or happily sign
it just to teach them the lesson and to
get into good practice and habit yeah
yes getting people and you've helped a
lot of people you know with this advice
people on the Academy so yeah so guys if
you listen to this podcast if you want
to get involved you want to meet band
you want to meet me you want to come
down see some of the projects if you're
a qualified investor in your new invest
head down to mock leader at UK if you
want to not just invest but if you've
got deals and you want to send them
through going to Matt leads Dakota UK
come and join come and join the money
the bar is big the pays the sky is the
limit so awesome man Ben thanks so much
for coming on or thanks for having some
difficulty getting him to come on open
up and share but he's done it he's the
man guys thank you for watching
I'll see you the next video
[Music]
you
[Music]